I had the idea to do a 10k Q&A sort of thing
about a month ago when I was at 9000 subscribers,
and somehow the passage of time took
place and now I’m creeping up on 15k,
so I don’t really know how that happened. But in
all seriousness, I appreciate the support, and,
I dunno, It’s cool to make things and have a lot
of people enjoy those things, so that’s been cool.
Thank you! Part of the reason I’m making this is
that I want to share some updates about what’s
going on with the channel and what I want to do
with it. You may have noticed that I”m posting
more recently, and indeed, I’m posting weekly
now, on thursdays. ANd I’m currently trying to
alternate between the higher effort content, the
deep dives into a particular deckbuilding subject,
and the more fun content, where I, for example,
analyze a precon, or just talk about whatever
it is I want to talk about that day. So
that’s currently what I’m trying to do,
and one particular type of off-week content
that I’m going to start next month is Patron
deck reviews. These deck reviews are going to
be very much in the style of the precon review,
so I’m going to try and figure out what a deck is
trying to do, how well it’s doing at that goal,
and some potential routes for improvement. So, as
I said, that’s going to be starting up next month.
I’m going to be picking decks through a lottery
system, and you can check out my Patreon for more
information about that. Also on my patreon, I’m
going to be posting a Glissa deck tech very soon,
so that’s two different reasons to check out my
Patreon, that’s pretty cool. With that out of the
way, let’s get to questions, and these are mostly
taken from a post I made on Patreon recently:
About a year ago I needed a username for some
website or other, and my two second on-the-spot
smash together of words was “Salubrious Snail”. A
few months later, I was trying to come up with a
name for my youtube channel, and that one popped
back into my brain, and I kind of liked it. It’s
snappy, it’s alliterative, it has a fun word,
seems pretty cool. So that’s what I went with.
I learned to play magic in 2011, and the way I got
into the game is that Mark Rosewater gave a career
day presentation at my middle school, and at the
end of it he handed all these little 11 and 12
year olds starter decks from M12 (I got the red
one) and then I just went from there. I started
playing limited in 2013, so my first draft was
Dragon’s Maze, and then in early 2014 I really got
into the game; I started playing standard and EDH.
I’ve played kind of off and on from them, picking
back up very heavily in early last year, starting
to build a whole bunch more commander decks.
I’ve always been a black player, and my first
deck that I can remember was a sort of black
lifegain-ish deck. It ran a lot of removal
because that’s just who I am as a player,
and the specific interaction I can remember
between two cards was that it had Tormented Soul,
an unblockable creature, and Vampire Outcasts, a
bloodthirst creature, one that enters larger if
an opponent was dealt damage this turn, so it
almost always enters as a 4 mana 4/4 lifelink,
which, honestly, not bad. Lifelink is
one of the best keywords. Pretty solid.
That one! Ashiok, Nightmare Weaver has always been
a card I love, and it’s funny because I feel like
it’s known for cube, y’know, you do the Splashiok,
but I’ve never played with it in cube. The place
I’ve played with it was in standard Grixis
control. I ran 3 of it, and it was fantastic.
In the faster matchups, it soaked up damage
for my deck, which sadly did not run lifegain,
and in the control matchups, of which there
were many because that was standard at the time,
all the abilities were great. The +2, you can
exile cards, which was great against Azorious
control which cycled through its deck repeatedly.
The -10, if your opponent lets you get up there,
just blows out a control deck, so just a
great card all around. I also love the flavor;
I’m a big horror fan, and the idea of this
unknowable, otherworldly entity that’s
weaponizing the fears of its foes to destroy
them, I love that. That’s incredible to me.
This is a good question, and I think for
starters it’s good to make sure that decks
are at similar at power levels. Figure out what
decks are doing, how fast they’re doing them,
and just make sure things are compatible and there
aren’t going to be crazy discrepancies. Secondly,
for middling to lower power levels, it’s good to
check in with what people’s intentions are for the
game and what they find fun. There are things
like board wipes or combos or heavy duty stax
pieces where people might not have as much fun if
they’re playing against these things; that might
not be a thing they want to see a lot of in their
game, and I think it’s fair to navigate that to
some extent. I will sometimes ask somebody not
to play a particular deck, even. For example,
I have a friend who has a Tergrid deck, and three
nights out of four I don’t want to play against
it. And I think that’s fair, although there
are some limits to what you can request of
somebody and it’s a tricky thing to navigate, you
can’t just ask that every deck your deck is bad
against isn’t in the game, that’s not really
fair. At the same time, when I build a deck,
if it’s a particularly feisty or mean or
suppressive deck I have some understanding
that it might see less action than a deck
that is nicer or offends people a little less.
So, the edh ban list is tricky because it’s
really trying to be two different things:
it’s trying to dictate what’s too strong for cEDH
and it’s also trying to dictate what’s not fun for
casual, and I think answering these two questions
at the same time is difficult. We can think about
some different cards we might think of banning.
Dockside Extortionist, for example—good card,
maybe it should be banned. But that would
mainly be a ban for cEDH and the top levels
of high power casual, because it doesn’t matter
for random midrange beats decks, there aren’t that
many artifacts at that power level, you aren’t
going to be doing the same sort of value loops,
it just won’t have the same horrifying power
level as in other EDH contexts. Similarly,
we can think about Armageddon. We could ban
it because it’s not fun, but that’s not a
ban in the conventional sense of a card game,
you’re not banning it because it’s too strong,
you’re banning it because it’s unfun. And I think
there is a little bit of tension there in trying
to solve two different problems. I wouldn’t be
that comfortable dictating a bunch of new card
allowances and disallowances for EDH because
I think it’s a really hard thing to do. What I
would encourage is players having more of a rule 0
conversation, a conversation about what they find
fun and what they don’t want to see in their game.
You shouldn’t roll up into a game with strangers
and blow up all their lands if they’re just trying
to play a game with upgraded precons or something.
I think it’s good to have an understanding about
that, and I think this is an acceptable solution,
since EDH is a social format fundamentally.
If I had to ban one card for very petty,
personal reasons, it would be Farewell. I hate
the card. I think it’s very lazy design. It’s
a 6 mana board wipe that has no downsides other
than that it’s a 6 mana board wipe; it’s probably
not broken from a power level stand point,
but I just hate to see it. It’s lazy. It also
crowds out other cards like Merciless Eviction or
Austere Command. So yeah, not a fan of Farewell.
The cat came back. I actually really like
explicitly political cards. Council’s Dilemma
and Will of the Council are both cool mechanics
with cool design space. It’s unfortunate that the
two cards from those that actually ended up being
good in EDH are some of the less interesting ones,
but I think there’s plenty of other design
space, and I think it’d be cool if they
printed more of those cards. I also think
goad is a super cool mechanic, love goad,
and I think it’d be cool to expand the mindset of
goad outside of creatures because I think goad has
a natural power limitation, that it’s not going
to be good above the beaty midrange power level,
and I think that’s a valid thing for a
card to be, but I think it’d be cool to
see more explicitly political cards that play
with other resources such as cards in hand.
Demonstrate, the mechanic where you can copy
a spell if you let your opponent have a copy,
I think that one is kind of cool, so yeah,
I think more stuff like that would be neat.
Sometime last year, I played against a
Tymna Jeska tribal ball lightning deck,
and that deck’s vision is splendid to me,
I love decks that take a really juicy,
powerful commander or pair of partner commanders
and use them for ridiculous ends. I just love that
and I love the idea of swinging with a ball
lightning for 18 at somebody’s face, that’s a
vision I can appreciate. I have to go with that
deck, that’s the only one that comes to mind.
I’ve gotten a handful of comments asking about the
cat post and the implied cat that goes with it,
and thankfully he made an appearance
for this. So this is my boy Niko,
he loves to bounce off the walls while
I’m trying to record, so yeah, great guy.